everywhere throughout the civilized world
people know the Street Broadway USA along
the street in the world but Broadway is the
street of many moves and we're going to see
most of them will follow Broadway through
the heart of New York from top to bottom
let's begin where New York ends Cochrane House
has been standing sent stagecoach days here's
Van Cortlandt Park station modern stagecoach
stop 218th street and Columbia University's
Baker field moving slowly downtown Dyckman
house at night one Street and Broadway now a
museum of Dutch colonial culture a reminder
that once the Dutch ruled Manhattan Island
still Broadway but a few blocks down our mood
changes The Cloisters highest point of Manhattan
Island here the culture is gothic and Romanesque
these are exact replicas of French cloisters
picturesque monastic settings art forms older
than democracy priceless treasures in stained
glass tell tales of peasants and of kings the
cloister arcades overlook the serene Hudson
River then 168th Street and Broadway Medical
Center a dozen streets downtown the espana
Society of America a Museum recalling an era when
Spain's explorers led the way to the New World
Spain's heroes emblazoned and stone
still stand watch on Broadway we
continue downtown past more Broadway
scenes and rapid changes of character
pausing briefly at the Jewish Theological
Seminary housing invaluable documents of
ancient Judaism off to the right
we can see general Grant's Tomb
Columbia University its famed statue of Albemarle
inviting those who seek knowledge one
of the world's great seats of learning
villo Colombia is the most densely populated
residential section in the world from 110th
Street to 72nd here Broadway's benches offer
rest and rendezvous like any small town
59th Street Columbus Circle to
please one heavy on the mustard
rising in the middle of Broadway
Christopher Columbus himself sharing
the circle a lesser-known monument of the
spanish-american war remember the main
ear to our hansom cabs four trips around
Central Park by day tourists by night lovers
at 59th Street Broadway touches Central
Park Central Park with its green grass
lakes and zoo extends from 59th to 110th
Street situated in the heart of Manhattan
it's the most valuable piece of real estate
in the world ever to be set aside as a park
back at Columbus Circle other landmarks high
over Broadway the right time the weather
immediately below Columbus Circle
New York's automobile district
just off-broadway at all Sentinel Radio City
back on Broadway father Duffy the
theatrical district with it shows
it's eateries it Snider ease Times
Square wonderland of lights the
Broadway everybody knows and The Times
building most famous of landmarks
42nd Street crossroads of the world
just south the Metropolitan Opera
House and a radio station Macy's of
Herald Square and considerable competition
the heralds of Herald Square sound the hour
Broadway in 23rd the eternal light
Union Square everything from
communism to vegetarianism
is discussed and because this is
America the arguments never stop
one of Broadway's many churches Grace Church
another great Broadway merchant John Wanamaker's
at night Street touching Manhattan's
Main Street with its air of bohemian
oddity Greenwich Village moving downtown
the Bowery Street of misery is a neighbor
the cross streets have
names here no longer numbers
Broadway cuts through the textile district
below Canal Street to City Hall here's an
interesting fact the uptown walls are of cheaper
construction the early city fathers felt Manhattan
was through growing and nobody would look
at that side of the building City Hall Park
just off Broadway the Brooklyn Bridge where Steve
Brodie took a dare and jumped
behind it the Manhattan Bridge
his business is picking up
speaking of business Wall
Street for Broadway the exchange
subtreasury building scene of Washington's
inauguration an historic Trinity Church
here old New York's elite worship and
many live Aryan Alexander Hamilton
Robert Fulton
New York's first part bowling green
still enclosed by the original iron fence
imported from England in 1771 Abraham
defy stir mayor of New York in 1691
the custom-house
seem from it a labyrinth
of brick granite and marble
surrounding Bowling Green is the
oldest neighborhood in Manhattan
now a monument to national
and international finance
number one Broadway once general
Washington's headquarters now
headquarters for great shipping lines
looking south from the battery the
Statue of Liberty symbol of America as
Broadway is the symbol of Main Street